it is considered the worst nuclear
disaster in history both in casualties
and in cost
36 years since the explosion at
chernobyl and the impacts are still
being felt by many today there's been
huge trauma there were a number of other
family members that were affected in
various ways ali galbar immigrated to
calgary from eastern europe with her
family in the 90s following the disaster
she says her uncle was part of the
cleanup crew and helped shovel out
reactor waste near the explosion
epicenter he survived but so many others
didn't he was very very sick like two
people of those 40 are still living the
rest had died we can't bring the world
to these kinds of
like
complete threats again but as war rages
on in ukraine the specter of another
nuclear disaster only grows it could be
by accident it could be by design but
there's no question that the nuclear
power stations are not meant to be in a
war zone and they were never designed to
be in a war zone on march 4th the
largest of ukraine's four nuclear plants
came under attack by russian forces and
has been in their control ever since
russia also controls chernobyl and is
advancing towards another facility north
of mikolaim i'm not particularly worried
about a nuclear event with
significant public radiation exposure
but this is a war zone and things are
very unpredictable this canadian nuclear
scientist is more worried about the
state of the operator still running the
facilities the nuclear power industry
operates with a lot of conservative
principles this is ingrained in
operating staff you make conservative
decisions you always err on the safe
side they follow procedures religiously
but i mean if you're under duress
that could be compromised the
international atomic energy agency has
made a plea to russia to allow outside
experts to visit the plants and
independently verify they are safe hanes
strongly agrees
it could help quell worried minds just
for a moment jamie dog local news
calgary